the internet wants to know the details
did you end up getting Wi-Fi for your
apartment no I'm still thinking about it
so yeah yes I want to go to the pros and
cons
um there's no cons lots of Pros but I
just don't put much at
um importance to it things that are
unimportant I just ignore yeah there's a
lot of things in life that have a lot of
Pros but like they're lower on the
priority list why why because the 5G
already he's got it covered do you watch
much video do you watch video do you
watch footage uh video footage quite
often yeah I I especially things from uh
Freestyle Wrestling record Roman
Wrestling Judo
um uh and mixed martial arts also uh
subsidiary Sports to mix martial arts
like boxing uh Muay Thai and European
kickboxing just for long-term idea
Generations
yeah this is an interesting thing how
could this be incorporated in the
context in which we use it MMA or jiu
jitsu
and maybe it's immediately obvious or it
might become obvious in in a few weeks
or months
is there some aspect to
um the way you approach life and
training and martial arts that amends
itself to minimalism it seems like you
live a pretty stoic life or is that just
a symptom of the focus you know my life
wasn't always like this I've gone
through different phases in my life I
was a university student and teacher at
University
um uh I was a nightclub bouncer for more
than a decade
um I've been through different areas of
life I've seen most things I've
experienced a lot I've traveled the
world
um uh at this point in my life people
think I live some kind of like monk-like
existence but um uh you know I I have a
private life I like to go out and have
fun like everyone else
um yeah I'm not like some kind of like
monk who just you know sits under a
waterfall and meditates for anything
crazy like that well that's that's what
I'm I'm currently going through that
stage of my life the monk-like existence